non certainement pas pire année de
l'histoire pas du tout du point de vue
du nombre de morts absolument pas même
pas pour une épidémie finalement je
trouve que le bon c'est un choc énorme
bien sûr un choc de santé qui met
l'économie vraiment en berne
mais c'est un choix qui permet de
montrer qu'on avait appris plein de
choses on sait faire plein de choses
l'europe réagit la banque centrale
européenne sur ses activités à bout de
bras le gouvernement en france soutient
par exemple l'activité
on pense le chômage partiel donc en fin
de compte on est capable de réagir en
est capable de faire front et s'adapte
et on fait de la recherche à toute
vitesse on découvre des vaccins dans
tous les pays et une europe se ressaisit
en fait sur deux domaines pas seulement
face au co but mais face à des risques
de démocratie libérale d'autres partis
de l'union européenne donc non voilà que
c'est un show qu'elle n'a tout le temps
il alignera toujours là il s'agit pas de
pays qui ce qui entre en guerre donc je
trouve que non face à ce choc négatif
c'est pas du tout la pire année de
l'histoire
vraiment
[Musique]